okay thank you all and thank you again
for coming I want to also thank Roger
Hertog for supporting this program as he
has this year and last year and next
year this is a research program on the
history and future of world problems and
and of course you know this this talk in
particular I think is one that really
brings it home when we look at the
problem of tuberculosis in New York City
how it came to be an epidemic but also
one of course that we can see in a more
global context and I'm sure that's going
to be part of the discussion as well and
who better than the James Colegrove to
to tell us about it he is someone who I
really think for for someone of his age
has been putting a lot of the rest of us
to shame and in terms of his research
and his publications is the author
editor now of three books and the latest
is epidemic city I would I would hold it
up if I'd remembered to bring it to the
podium with me it was just published a
couple weeks ago epidemic city is there
it is he's also selling it out of the
back of his car he's we're gonna pull it
up and after the talk but I'm just
kidding so so it's a it's a history of
Public Health in New York City and as
you know we've just been discussing now
James was kind enough to talk with our
students talk with kavita severa my
Christian students he's been talking now
for for three hours already I should
tell you you know New York City has
really been at the forefront in many
ways in dealing with problems of Public
Health it's it's been a model for for
other jurisdictions around the United
States and for other countries around
the world and so here again even if
we're bringing it home tonight and
looking at tuberculosis in New York
we're doing so in a global context and I
know that we're going to learn a lot
from it so let me just finish by also
thanking the others who made this
possible I'm thinking of the Center for
the history and ethics of public health
at Columbia's Melman school thank you
David and I want to thank to the
communications department of the Melman
School that provided the the
refreshments tonight so with no further
ado let me turn things over to Professor
James Colegrove at the mailman school
thank you thank you Matt for that very
nice introduction and thank you all for
coming tonight tuberculosis is a disease
of unparalleled global significance
about a third of the world's people are
infected with TB an estimated 1.7
million people died from the disease in
2009 TB is the classic disease of
deprivation and poverty it spreads where
people lack basic material needs
adequate and stable housing employment
and access to health care a my talk this
evening I'm going to present a TB
success story that followed a series of
notorious public health failures in the
1980s and 1990s New York City
experienced a deadly resurgence of TB
the strategy that brought the disease
under control proved to be an
influential model for policy at the
World Health Organization and is still
cited today as an example from which
public health professionals globally can
learn exactly what lessons are to be
drawn from these events may not be
straightforward however there is a
long-standing debate as I think all of
you know within public health about
whether the most effective and durable
way to reduce disease is to address the
root causes of disease that is the
underlying social and economic
circumstances of people's lives or
whether it's to use targeted
interventions like antibiotics vaccines
and other technical solutions that leave
broader social conditions untouched
which approach is more effective which
approach is more ethical the story of TB
control in New York City exemplifies the
tensions between these two alternative
approaches oops
when did I do that
all right leo maker 38 years old
homeless drug-addicted
and sick with tuberculosis seemed to
personify at least in the minds of the
editors of the New York Post the social
disorder engulfing New York City when
the post ran a full-page photo of him on
its cover next to the headline one man's
trail of TB this was the first in a
series of articles on the disease in the
fall of 1990 a time when the city was
reeling under the effects of severe
budgetary shortfalls a skyrocketing
murder rate the seemingly uncontrollable
spread of AIDS and the effects of the
epidemic of crack cocaine TB resurged
among the city's poorest and most
troubled residents the rate of disease
among welfare recipients who abused
alcohol or drugs was 70 times as high as
the rate for the u.s. population overall
the problem was most severe in Harlem a
neighborhood that had long symbolized
and epitomized deprivation in the midst
of affluence in 1990 New York City held
3 percent of the country's population
but accounted for 15% of its TB cases
this problem had been years in the
making by the time this story ran rates
of TB in the city had been rising for
more than a decade and a looming crisis
had been predicted by numerous advisory
panels community groups and experts
inside and outside of government so how
did New York City end up in this dire
situation why had TB a disease treatable
with antibiotics researched and why had
rates continued to rise for more than a
dozen years before an effective control
program was put in place answering those
questions will help to make clearer the
significance of what New York City did
and didn't do to remedy the problem so
to understand the roots of the problem
we have to go back several decades and
look at the evolving medical management
of TB so first a bit of medical
background that may be familiar to you
TB is an airborne disease caused by a
bacillus that most commonly attacks the
law
although it can attack other organs as
well in most patients the infection
remains latent and asymptomatic patients
have a roughly 10 percent lifetime risk
of progressing to active symptomatic
illness that risk is increased when
patients immune systems are weakened
symptoms include severe cough fever
weight loss and fatigue when patients
are not symptomatic they are not
infectious but when they become
symptomatic they can pass the disease on
to others through airborne droplets as
in coughing or sneezing so later on in
my talk when I refer to cases of TB I'm
going to be talking about active
symptomatic cases before the mid 20th
century there was no effective treatment
for TB in the standard therapy consisted
of several months of bed rest often in a
sanitarium like the one shown here in
the post-world War two ERA however the
development of several new antibiotics
transformed the medical management of TB
these new drugs could cure TB and they
allowed patients to be treated on an
ambulatory basis New York City
established a network of outpatient
clinics dispensing oral antibiotics the
shift from an inpatient to an outpatient
model of care brought a new set of
challenges however a full course of
therapy typically took six to nine
months but the acute symptoms of the
disease generally subsided after a few
weeks at which point many patients no
longer feeling ill stopped taking their
medication and the failure to complete
therapy led to the development of
resistant strains of the bacillus and as
we'll see later on the development of
drug resistance would play a critical
role in subsequent events by the time
antibiotics were introduced the case
rate and the death rate for TB had been
declining for many decades for reasons
that are somewhat in dispute among
historical demographers and others who
study long-term trends in morbidity and
mortality one thing that was almost
certainly responsible for the decline
was improvements in housing so for
example things like stricter building
codes that limited the amount of
overcrowding in tenements but the
introduction of antibiotics clearly had
an impact on further driving down the
case rate and the death rate so this
chart is a little busy so let me walk
you through it there's two sets of lines
here okay so these are the TB case rates
and this is the TB death rate from 1930
through the end of the 1960s and the
three lines the top line in each case is
New York City this is New York State
including New York City and this is New
York State outside of New York City and
two things to draw your attention to
first of all the most obvious thing is
the difference between the case state
rate and the death rate in New York City
compared to at the rest of the state how
much higher it is so New York State has
New York City has a much higher rate and
then notice that there's an overall
downward trend that except that is
accelerated by antibiotics so you can
see that the trend it's a little bumpy
it's a little up and down but was
steadily declining and then around the
early 1950s with the widespread
deployment of antibiotics the rates of
both declined even further the drop and
the death rate is quite dramatic that
decline in the case rate is a little
less that they both the decline is
accelerated by the create the
introduction of antibiotics
so this decline coincided excuse me
coincided with another historical trend
which was the increasing concentration
of the disease among the poor
there was widespread agreement during
this period the 1960s that social
problems were at the root of
tuberculosis and so the best way to
fight the disease was to address these
underlying issues in 1967 a report by
the City Health Department's Bureau of
tuberculosis made the following comment
they said quote probably the most
important preventive measure in
tuberculosis is improvement of the
socio-economic conditions of the
population most at-risk
this requires improved housing education
and job opportunities and stabilization
of the family the report went on such
activities are not within the framework
of the Bureau of tuberculosis but
increasingly we should concern ourselves
with these social aspects of health
maintenance well in fact the Health
Department did not end up concerning
itself with these social aspects of
health maintenance on the contrary what
happened next was something that has
often happened in the history of public
health success bred complacency and over
the next decade tuberculosis was
increasingly ignored concern about TB
dwindled as medical and public health
professionals grew convinced that
infectious diseases no longer
represented a significant threat in the
u.s. if you're in the Hertog Institute
classes this summer you've heard this in
your classes and you know from your
other lectures in this series that there
was a widespread perception during the
60s and 70s that we didn't need to be
worried about contagious diseases
anymore we had conquered contagions a
couple weeks ago Matt quoted an expert
from the early 70s saying whatever the
future of infectious disease holds we
can be sure it will be dull right and
that believe certainly extended to the
belief that we just didn't need to be
worried about TB anymore at the same
time there was a waning of the Great
Society liberal belief in activist
government particularly the belief that
the government should try to ameliorate
the problems
the inner-city poor during the 1960s and
the federal war on poverty ambitious
social programs had flourished an annual
federal spending on health climbed
steadily but with the election of
Richard Nixon in 1968 the idea of
activist government the idea of activist
government went into retreat
particularly in Nixon's second term
particularly in Nixon's second term when
the administration made deep cuts to
spending on Health and Social Welfare it
was within this context that New York
City's TB control programs were almost
completely dismantled in the 1970s the
majority of the city's TB control
programs were paid for with state
federal and state funding and during the
1970s virtually all of that funding was
withdrawn so that by 1980 local tax
revenues supported virtually all of the
city's TB control efforts this would
have put an enormous strain on local
fiscal resources under the best of
circumstances and as many of you know
the 1970s were certainly not the best of
circumstances for New York City in 1974
New York City collapsed into fiscal
insolvency for years the city had been
spending more money than it took in and
borrowing to cover the difference and
this untenable strategy came to an end
when lenders the big banks decided that
the city was no longer a good credit
risk and and refused to continue
underwriting the city's debt the city
was forced to make drastic reductions in
municipal services police fire
sanitation and higher education does
anyone remember who was the mayor of New
York City in 1975 very good you guys are
good a B people don't usually remember
poor Abe Beame he was a rather
colourless character and who was the
President Gerald Ford right so in the
fall of 1975 a beam went to Washington
to plead for a federal bailout from
President Ford President Ford turned him
down prompting one of the Daily News
most famous tabloid headlines Abe is a
beam Carrie is new
State Governor Hugh Carey the health
department which was responsible for
coordinating TB control in the city was
one of the hardest hit by some measures
the hardest hit of any city agency
during the city's fiscal crisis between
1974 and 1977 the health department lost
a quarter of its staff going from around
6000 employees to around 4,500 there
were major cuts in virtually all program
areas including TB control five of the
department's 15 outpatient TB clinics
were closed and the Bureau of TB control
lost 83 employees more than half of its
staff including critically almost all of
the field investigators whose job it was
was to visit patients in the community
to monitor their progress with their
medication and to encourage them to
continue taking their medication the
outreach staff following more than 2,000
ambulatory patients in the city fell
from 22 to and you can probably do the
math on that yourself but yes that does
come out to a caseload of about a
thousand patients per caseworker there
remained in the city a small community
of TB experts who were not convinced
that infectious disease was conquered
and for them the effects of these cuts
was not difficult to predict when the
state halved its financial contribution
in 1978 and signaled that it would soon
end its support completely the health
department's director of TB control
prepared a report titled tuberculosis
control and impending crisis the report
stated bluntly tuberculosis is not under
control in New York City the report
noted that the TB rate in the city was
around twice the national average and
that in the neighborhoods of Harlem the
Lower East Side and Bedford Stuyvesant
it was six times the national average
commenting on the imminent withdrawal of
funding the report predicted
tuberculosis cases will go unreported
and unsupervised tuberculosis contacts
will go undetected the untreated cases
will walk in the streets of New York the
unexamined contacts will break down and
feed the city's TB reservoir and as it
happened all of these predict
turned out to be exactly true the
following year the TB case rate rose for
the first time in more than two decades
the rise in cases prompted a small
infusion of resources in 1980 using a
combination of city and federal money
the health department hired 21 new
outreach workers to monitor patients the
following year however several staff
members whose salaries were paid for by
the CDC had to be let go because of cuts
to public health spending in the Reagan
administration's first budget over the
next four years the city's TB control
infrastructure was the subject of three
detailed and highly critical reports
which documented a litany of clinical
administrative problems that resulted in
the systematic failure of patients to
receive adequate care because infectious
disease medicine was seen as a kind of
clinical backwater the city had a very
difficult time recruiting high-caliber
physicians to work in its TB clinics as
a result patients were often often
received substandard care for example
being placed on drug regimens to which
they had documented resistance patients
drifted away from care because there
were insufficient staff and resources to
follow them the inadequate clinical
management of T V was evident in patient
outcomes the CDC recommended that in any
jurisdiction 90% of patients should
convert to non-infectious status within
six months of beginning treatment in New
York City only about 50% of patients did
the dismantling of the TB control
infrastructure laid the groundwork for
the resurgence of TB in New York City
and at this point two additional factors
combined to increase rates of illness in
the city
the first factor was the increase in the
city of poverty and homelessness in the
1970s some 250,000 blue-collar jobs
disappeared from New York City the
result partly of broad-based changes in
the regional and national economy the
percentage of city residents living in
poverty rose from 1/5
to 1/4 the city lost much of its
low-income housing
stock in the 1970s and beginning in 1981
the Reagan administration gutted federal
housing assistance to the poor all of
these factors combined to create a large
population of homeless and unstable e
housed men women and children between
1960 and 1980 the average number of
homeless families in the city's
temporary shelters was around 600 per
month by the mid-1980s that number had
risen to around 5,000 per month TV had
long been recognized as a particular
problem of the homeless the transient
disordered existence of people living on
the streets made taking pills and
keeping medical appointments difficult
in the dormitory style shelters that
became commonplace in the 1980s such as
the infamous Fort Washington Armory
shelter directly across the street from
the Columbia School of Public Health
which was the ideal setting for the
spread of airborne contagions really the
spread of contagions of all sorts but
particularly airborne contagions as New
York City began to warehouse thousands
of people in these environments the
number of TB cases diagnosed among
shelter residents climbed steadily
the problem was particularly severe
among homeless alcoholics whose weakened
immune systems made them vulnerable to
reactivation of latent infection the
second factor that proved to be critical
in the resurgence of TB was the
appearance in the city of AIDS this is
the first article from the New York
Times on the mysterious cases of immune
suppression that had begun to appear in
the city although initial attention
focused on cases among homosexual men it
soon became apparent that the disease
was also spreading rapidly among
injection drug users and their sexual
partners and within a few years the
majority of new AIDS cases in the city
were being diagnosed in drug users and
more than half the city's AIDS cases
were black or Hispanic a 1985 report by
a non-governmental Health Organization
noted that the groups most affected by
AIDS and TB were the same black and
Hispanic males aged 25 to 44 and that a
diagnosis of one disease in this group
closely preceded or file
another the report observed quote
traditionally compromised immunity among
those infected with TB has resulted in
disease it is plausible to suggest that
epidemic immune deficiency may be
associated with increased TB incidents
several studies published over the next
few years verified this speculation
people with AIDS were far more likely to
progress to active TB than those who
were not immune compromised as Karen
brodny a physician who treated homeless
patients at Harlem Hospital put it in a
subsequent article she said quote the
advent of HIV in the 1980s poured oil on
the smoldering coals of TB among the
homeless this chart shows the incidence
of TB in the city over about 30 years
from 1978 to a couple of years ago and
you can see in this chart the effects of
the three factors that I've just
outlined the dismantling of TB control
infrastructure poverty and homelessness
and epidemic immune deficiency so recall
that my pointer here recall that the
trend line had been going down for many
decades in a steady downward trend in
1978 cases tick back up for the first
time in decades as a result of the
dismantling of the TB the city's TB
control programs cases continue it at a
somewhat elevated rate for several years
and then in the mid 1980s beginning
around 85 and 86 you see the combined
and synergistic effects of homelessness
poverty and HIV and then rates continued
to rise over the rest of the decade by
1992 when cases peaked in New York City
the city recorded more than 3,500 cases
of the disease more than triple the
number of cases in 1978 when rates had
begun to creep back up this map shows
the geographic distribution of New York
City's TB cases in 1992 the year that
cases peaked on this map each dot
represents a case of TB and the map is
divided into census block group
that are shaded according to the level
of poverty and a darker level of shading
indicates a higher level of poverty and
you can see a very clear pattern in here
of high concentration of dots in the
darker areas of the map with higher
poverty so my pointer so we are here in
the little island of Colombia surrounded
by Harlem a very very traditionally high
poverty area with this city's highest
clustering of TB cases and you see a
similar pattern in here in the South
Bronx on the lower Eastside this is of
course before Whole Foods came to the
Lower East Side and it became a
gentrified playground for the wealthy
this is Bedford Stuyvesant and of course
conversely you see the opposite pattern
in the very lightly shaded areas very
few dots so the Upper East Side and
Midtown East very few dots that
relatively affluent suburbs of Queens
Bayside and Forest Hills
very few dots a very clear correlation
between the TB case rate and poverty as
rates were rising in the late 1980s
public pressure built on the city to do
something City Councilmembers state
assembly members and other politicians
began to put pressure on Mayor Ed Koch
who in turn pressured various city
agencies to address the problem
including the Health Department the
city's public hospitals and the human
resources administration which ran the
city's homeless shelters but the city's
response remained incoherent and
inadequate public health was chronically
underfunded during these years and many
public health leaders were lulled into
thinking that because TB was at least in
theory treatable with antibiotics it did
not pose a severe threat as has often
been the case in the history of Public
Health it would take an urgent crisis to
spur action and that urgent crisis
arrived in the form of outbreaks of TB
resistant to multiple drugs so-called
MDR TB or multi drug-resistant
tuberculosis cases of MDR TB began to
strike in institutional
settings in 1990 a dozen inmates and one
guard died of mdr-tb in jails in Queens
and upstate and Syracuse
around the same time local hospitals
began reporting outbreaks of MDR TB
among their patients so recall that I
mentioned earlier that the potential
problem of drug resistance had been
recognized as early as the 1950s but
drug-resistant cases had never
represented a significant number of
cases in the US and in fact by the mid
1980s the CDC had become so convinced
the drug resistance was not a problem in
the u.s. that had stopped conducting
systematic surveillance of
drug-resistant cases so when these new
cases began to occur it was impossible
to know if they were anomalies or if
they represented a wider epidemic that
question was answered by a young
physician epidemiologist with the CDC
who was on assignment in New York City
with the Health Department named Tom
Frieden who of course as many of you
know is now the head of the CDC with
three assistants Frieden trekked to 72
hospitals around the city collecting
sputum samples from patients who had
been diagnosed with TB in the spring of
1991 and he did drug susceptibility
testing on those and what he found was
even worse than what many people had
feared 20% of patients had strains
resistant to both isoniazid and rifampin
in the two first-line drugs a third of
patients were infected with strains of
TB resistant to at least one of the
standard drugs although the strongest
predictor of having a drug-resistant
strain was the history of having
received prior treatment as you might
expect the majority of patients with
drug-resistant strains were initially
infected with the drug-resistant strains
officials at the CDC were so alarmed by
the high rates that Frieden and his team
uncovered that they did a nationwide
survey that found that New York City
accounted for more than half the cases
of drug-resistant TB in the country the
public health implications of these
findings were grave the case fatality
rate 40 be resistant to two or more
drugs is 40 to 60% treating drug wars
strains involves an even more
complicated medication regimen that can
take as long as two years to complete it
was the emergence of widespread drug
resistance and the drain the danger that
these new strains posed in occupational
settings to healthcare workers and other
hospital employees to police officers
child welfare workers prison guards and
others that was the critical factor in
bringing public attention to the problem
the mayor at this time at the time that
drug resistant strains began to appear
in the city was David Dinkins and as his
health commissioner Dinkins appointed
Margaret Hamburg who spoke in this
lecture a couple of weeks ago she of
course is now the head of the Food and
Drug Administration when Dinkins
appointed her she was only 36 years old
she was the youngest health commissioner
in the city's history Dinkins appointed
her right around the time that the
problem of drug resistance was becoming
apparent and as soon as she assumed the
job hamburg moved Swick swiftly against
tuberculosis one of the first things she
did was to appoint Tom Frieden the
director of the Bureau of TB control one
of the other first things she did was to
get more money for the problem it was
clear that the magnitude of the problem
outstripped the local resources that New
York City could marshal and that federal
financial support would be necessary
Congress had authorized the CDC to spend
36 million dollars nationwide to fight
TB but only 15 million of that had
actually been appropriated Hamburg wrote
to members of the state's congressional
delegation she drafted a letter for
mayor Dinkins to send to the US
Secretary of Health and Human Services a
House subcommittee held hearings on TB
in late 1991 and in the wake of that
hearing Congress made an emergency
appropriation of about 100 million
dollars to the CDC's budget for TB
control of that amount New York City
received 40 million because non
adherence to medication had played such
an important role in the emergence and
spread of drug-resistant strains it was
clear that the city was going to have to
adopt much more aggressive means of
increasing patients treatment completion
that is the percentage of patients who
completed their full course of TB
medication so I'd like to see a show of
hands sir please raise your hand if you
have ever been prescribed a course of
antibiotics for any reason okay keep
your hands that put them up high please
keep your hand up if you always have
taken every single pill you were
prescribed all the way down to the very
last pill oh come on you guys aren't
telling the truth okay thank you this is
interesting you know I asked this
question every I ask this question every
year to my public health students and
they also always keep their hands up but
I never know if it is because public
health students aren't a representative
sample or if there's some kind of social
desirability bias going on so if you put
your hand down please go stand in the
corner now if you put your hand down
don't feel bad because you're actually
in very good company there's a very big
literature on non compliance and
non-compliance with medication orders
and that literature is very clear and
consistent people are not good at taking
their medication for patients young and
old male and female well-to-do and
indigent in the developing world and an
economically advanced nations
non-compliance with medication orders
appears to be a universal tendency one
expert on compliance wrote quote the
individual who uses new drugs on a
routine basis without help and
encouragement from others is probably
the abnormal one so you all are abnormal
TB presents a much more difficult
problem than most diseases it's treated
with multiple pills that can have very
unpleasant gastrointestinal side effects
as I mentioned earlier symptoms abate
soon after treatment has begun but
several more months of medication are
necessary before the patient is cured
directly observed therapy or d-o-t in
which outreach workers monitor the
patient's watching them as they swallow
the pills was an attempt to address this
problem DoD had first been used by
public health officials in Hong Kong and
med
India in the 1950s and had been very
successful there at achieving high
treatment completion rates in the US
however only a few local and state
health officials had adopted d-o-t
because the costs were seen as
unjustified given that race of TB were
on the decline and after all we didn't
need to be worried about infectious
diseases anymore
DoD raised several ethical and pragmatic
concerns which Peggy Hamburg and Tom
Frieden had to confront as they
considered implementing it in New York
City who should be placed on d-o-t
homeless patients and injection drug
users while these groups were more
likely than others to be non-compliant
what the problem was by no means limited
to these groups one study found that
about half of all patients stopped
taking their medication for at least two
months should do t therefore be offered
to every patient as a default should it
be required of every patient was
requiring patients to be watched while
they swallow their pills a coercive and
paternalistic intrusion on patient
privacy would putting all patients on
observation wastes scarce resources on
patients who might otherwise take their
pills without assistance would do t send
a stigmatizing message that health
officials believed patients couldn't be
trusted or would universal do t reduce
stigma by normalizing the process of
taking medication under observation
Hamburg and Frieden ultimately decided
that the city would implement a policy
of universal do t patients in theory
could opt out of the program but the
Health Department presented it to
patients newly on therapy as this is
what we do they've that was the line
this is just the way we do it so
probably many patients had the
impression that they had no choice but
to take their medication under
observation and if a patient opted out
of do T but then subsequently was found
not to be taking their medication he or
she could then be ordered to take the
pills under mandatory do t in early 1992
there were just a handful of patients
receiving do t under a small CDC funded
pilot program and as you can see from
this chart
over the next three years the number of
patients on d-o-t climbed steadily so
that by the end of 1995 approximately
80% of all paid TB patients in the city
were receiving d-o-t and not shown on
this chart about 90% of patients who had
multidrug-resistant TB were receiving
d-o-t a huge core of outreach workers
was hired to implement this program a
big chunk of the 40 million dollar
emergency appropriation that the city
received went towards hiring several
hundred outreach workers to administer
d-o-t there were two primary forms of do
t1 was clinic based in which patients
came daily or twice weekly to receive
their medication the other consisted of
community-based appointments at sites
that the patient's themselves chose
homes and workplaces were the most
common venues for receiving do T but the
outreach workers went to every
imaginable location they went to welfare
hotels to crack dens to street corners
to train stations to homeless
encampments anywhere the patients were
in some cases the sites for do Qi
appointments were chosen because the
patients didn't want their families
friends or coworkers to know they were
being treated for TB but in many cases
it was because the patient had no stable
residence or employment if do Qi raised
concerns about its potentially coercive
aspects another key component of this of
the city's TB control program was even
more sensitive and potentially
controversial involuntary confinement of
non-compliant patients detention had a
longer history than do T and an even
more checkered one having often been
used against the disadvantaged of
society when antibiotic therapies had
had been introduced in the 1950s more
than 30 states used involuntary
hospitalization for patients who were
deemed unlikely to complete treatment
and as you can imagine that judgment was
often influenced by social prejudices
with alcoholics and the homeless being
much more likely to be subject to
detention in New York City the Health
Department had used detention on a very
limited
for persistently non-adherent patients
in the 1970s and the 1980s this is an
example well you can read this of a TB
detention order from the city health
department to a treating physician and I
blacked out the name of the patient can
you all read that in the back so at the
top it says please be advised that
because this patient has infectious
communicable pulmonary tuberculosis and
because she has demonstrated a lack of
concern for her own well-being and a
severe lack of cooperation regarding
medical treatment in order to detain has
been issued and down here in in this
paragraph you can see the specifics of
the detention a 24-hour guard should be
placed on the patient any attempt to
escape from the hospital should be
thwarted it is advised that all personal
belongings
he's clothing be taken away to expedite
treatment no passes are to be issued etc
and I should note at this time that the
city did not have a locked TB ward
dedicated to the care of TB patients
under detention each time one of these
orders was issued the treating hospital
had to arrange for a guard to be
stationed outside that patients door and
this is the order that was given to the
patient herself a detention order has
been placed on you this means you are
not allowed to leave the hospital
etc now note here on the last line it
says you may appeal to the Board of
Health
pursuant to section 5.2 one of the
health code as New York City
contemplated what was likely to be an
expansion of the use of detention one of
the things that had to be done was that
the health code had to be amended so why
was this necessary well the health code
granted very broad discretion to the hep
to the health commissioner and it
provided no explicit guarantee of due
process for the detainee this was a
problem because over the previous two
decades courts around the country had
issued an array of influential decisions
expanding protections for individuals
against government coercion many of
these were in the realm of criminal
justice famous cases like the case that
required now the Miranda ruling getting
the Wainright which required defendants
for indigent
criminal defendants but many of these
cases came out of the realm of Medicine
so for example commitment statutes for
people with mental illness drug
addiction and alcoholism had to ensure
that the people detained were able to
contest their confinement before a judge
in 1980 the West Virginia Supreme Court
struck down a statute for the detention
of TB patients because the patients were
being held without written notice and
right to counsel
although the constitutionality of New
York City's TB provisions had never been
challenged it was clear that they were
not going to stand up to court scrutiny
so in April of 1983 the Board of Health
approved a package of amendments to the
health code under these amendments
patients could be ordered to take their
medication under direct observation and
if patients failed to comply they could
be detained involuntarily in an
inpatient facility not just until they
were non-infectious which could happen
in a few weeks that until they were
completely cured which in the case of
MDR TB could take up to 24 months under
the new provisions of the health code
the health department had to inform the
patient of the right to be represented
by an attorney and to provide an
attorney if the patient asked for one
the patient requested release the
Commissioner had to respond before the
court within 72 hours the city
established two locked TB wards
dedicated to the care of TB patients a
25 bed ward in Goldwater Memorial
Hospital on Roosevelt Island and a 21
bed ward at Bellevue on the east side
both of which opened in 1993 the
Goldwater Ward has since been closed but
the city still operates a lot TB ward at
Bellevue Hospital in the mid-1980s fewer
than a dozen patients had been detained
each year for persistent non-compliance
in the two years following the revisions
to the health code 139 patients were
detained for those with drug susceptible
TB the medians day was 21 weeks for
those with multi drug-resistant TB the
median stay was just under a year the
percentage of patients detained overall
was quite small it was only a
2% of all patients but everyone
associated with the TB control program
agreed that a credible threat of
detention was critical to the success of
d-o-t that his patients were told if you
don't cooperate with your DoD outreach
worker you will be sent to a locked
Hospital facility as the city was
formulating its plan for compulsory
d-o-t in detention many civil liberties
advocates argued that these measures
were a misguided diversion from the real
issue at hand addressing the social and
economic problems that lay at the root
of TB Jorge anis a public health legal
scholar and ethicist writing in the New
England Journal of Medicine around the
time that New York City's control
program was going into effect voiced a
widespread view when he said that do T
and detention quote concentrate on the
victims of social neglect rather than on
the neglect itself anis went on this
focus is understandable since poverty is
a much more difficult problem to address
than the treatment of tuberculosis but
the history of the disease shows that
success in controlling tuberculosis
depends much more on the general
standard of living than on specific
medical or legal interventions so
whether or not this is true is an open
question this is this the graph that I
showed you earlier and you can see how
beginning in 1992 when the cities in a
control program of d-o-t and attention
went into effect how quickly the cases
came down by the end of 1993 some 18
months after the strengthened program
began to be put into place the number of
TB cases had in the city had declined by
15 percent from the previous year the
following year new cases dropped even
further for a two year decline of more
than 20% the portion of patients
completing their treatment rose from
about half to about 90% and the
percentage of cases that were
drug-resistant declined from 1/3 to 1/4
and this decline as you can see has
continued ever since and just a few
months ago the City Health Department
released a news release saying that
cases of TB in the city were at an
all-time low so this is the press
conference in the spring of 1994 where
the Health Department announced the
second sharp drop in TB cases that's Tom
Frieden at the lectern flanked by Peggy
Hamburg and Mayor Rudy Giuliani the
following year Tom Frieden went to India
to work under the auspices of the World
Health Organization where he marshaled a
massive effort using directly observed
therapy and achieved
similarly remarkable improvements in the
detection and cure of patients also the
following year in 1995 the World Health
Organization announced that its new
strategy for the control of TB would
have directly observed therapy as its
centerpiece New York City's approach had
targeted one of the most important
factors contributing to the unchecked
spread of TB it had strengthened the
inadequate clinical management of TB and
increased treatment completion rates the
rate the percentage of patients
completing their treatment through
universal d-o-t I should note also that
one of the other important things that
the city did was at the Health
Department undertook a major hiring of
new better trained physicians to work in
the city's TB clinics and they did a
major staff training and education
effort throughout the city's hospitals
to ensure that the quality of clinical
care improved what the city's control
program did not knew was what the Health
Department had urged it to do back in
the 1960s in that memo that I quoted to
you earlier it did not address the
underlying social factors that fueled
the epidemic the program of directly
observed therapy worked within
structures of poverty and deprivation
welfare hotels homeless encampments
crack dens neighborhoods devastated by
the federal war on drugs rather than
attempting to reform them homelessness
did not decrease in New York City in the
1990s punitive narcotics laws that
marginalized injection drug users and
devastated 4km
were not repealed drug treatment was not
expanded New York City's economy boomed
in the 1990s but these gains did not
accrue equally to all city residents
instead economic polarization reached
unprecedented levels over the 1990s
those involved was the city's TB program
were not unaware of the need to address
the underlying social pathologies that
fostered the spread of TB but the
urgency of the situation that confronted
the city in 1991 with spiraling rates of
disease and the emergence of widespread
drug resistance tested the health
department's commitment to those ideals
Tom Frieden defending the use of
detention in a presentation to the Board
of Health made the following comment he
did not he did not dispute that the
people most likely to be targets of
coercive measures were already
disadvantaged in many other ways that he
said quote although society is in part
responsible for this situation this
doesn't mean no action should be taken
to continue to allow these individuals
to infect others compounds social
injustice with deplorable inaction
similarly Margaret Hamburg commenting on
the tension between the need to attack
the root causes of disease and the
imperative to act quickly to prevent
sickness and death put the matter this
way she said quote we cannot afford to
hold off on TB control efforts and wait
until a damaged society is repaired for
public health professionals committed to
ideals of social justice this dilemma
continues to frame TB control globally
and this is particularly true where
problems of drug resistance raise the
level of urgency in 2006 health
officials in South Africa reported the
emergence of so-called XDR TB or
extensively drug-resistant tuberculosis
which is resistant not only to the two
first-line drugs but also to at least
three of the six classes of second line
drugs once again New York City provided
a potential model for how
the disease might be controlled Jerome
Singh and his colleagues raising the
possibility that detention might be used
for some patients wrote quote emulation
of New York's approach in controlling
its TB outbreak could empower health
officials in South Africa and elsewhere
to act decisively in tackling emerging
XDR TB and MDR TB epidemics the control
of drug-resistant TB in New York City in
the 1990s was undoubtedly a triumph one
that has since been widely cited in
journals of medicine and public health
as a case study of what can be
accomplished when the basic tools at
public health are applied with
sufficient funding commitment and skill
that it was an essentially technocratic
solution is not necessarily inconsistent
with the commitment to social change
working in the context of profound
injustice Peggy Hamburg Tom Frieden and
their colleagues saw the health
department's TB control effort as a form
of justice to the extent that it
relieved the disproportionate burdens
that illness places on the disadvantaged
but whether the strengthening of TB
control infrastructure in a given
jurisdiction has a positive neutral or
perhaps even a negative effect on more
thoroughgoing social reform is both an
empirical question and an ethical
challenge we must confront in light of
the profound inequities that
characterize global public health so
I'll conclude with a shameless bit of
self-promotion if you'd like to read
more about this my publisher would be
very happy if you bought my book so
thank you very much for your attention
and I'll be happy to hear your questions
all right well what a night goes the
first question oh yeah so you said that
uh this you know at the end that is
question of whether a very effective and
very you know focus public health
intervention like the one that New York
City undertook with regards to
tuberculosis whether that actually makes
it you know less likely then that a city
and and a community will address the
underlying causes of a condition like
tuberculosis is an empirical question so
so what kind of empirical research do
think might might help us might help
some of these students you know for
instance begin to to address that
question yeah yeah I mean it's it's a
it's a I think it's a really important
question to the extent I did it asked us
to think about what public health as an
enterprise does in society my colleague
up at the School of Public Health Connie
Nathanson who's a sociologist has a
great line that she likes to quote that
says public health was designed to
forestall revolutions not to foment them
and the idea is that by making
conditions tolerable for people at the
bottom of the social ladder and ensuring
that diseases that might affect them
don't spread to the more well-to-do that
buttresses the existing social order and
so one place to look for empirical
research would certainly be during the
sanitary revolution of the nineteenth
century
when major urban centers in Europe and
the u.s. started undertaking public
health reforms that were broad-based in
nature and were looking at things like
you know can changes in employment
conditions
in housing and other basic material
conditions of people's lives and then
compare that to later public health
reform efforts at other points in the
20th century that were more technical or
to their critics technocratic in nature
that involved things that didn't address
these underlying underlying conditions
okay great thank you James all right so
the first question from the audience
hiya thank you first of all this is nice
you have like a little a little stand
for your question you guys could just
remain seated I think if you want okay
so in this map that you showed earlier
in the presentation you noted this
correlation between yes I guess I'll
bring it up but correlation between I
guess poverty stricken areas or just
impoverished areas and cases of TB but
just statistically like if your example
if you look at some of the whitened
areas there are still cases there so
statistically it seems probable that
there might be a couple of cases of TB
possibly of MDR XDR qualities that still
remain dormant in in certain I guess in
certain people in those areas in those
whited out areas so first of all would
you agree with this assessment that some
XDR TB or MDR TB still exists might
exist today but the cave that black dots
are symptomatic cases these are active
cases of TB so these would not record
latent or asymptomatic cases right but
if there are if there are symptomatic
cases in a region then it makes sense
there would also be asymptomatic cases
there as well right mmm-hmm right so
first of all what do you think that
possibly in xdr-tb strain might exist in
a latent like one of these whited out
regions and second of all do you think
that today we're prepared to combat the
threat if such an xdr-tb strain surfaces
well so for the first part I mean say
it's a good question I mean I think what
the map shows is the extent to which
that the conditions may foster the the
reactivation of latent infection for
reasons that we either know or we may
not know having
do with things like depressed you know
the depressed nutritional status poor
overall health status I mean this map
would be the same for many other
illnesses right I mean virtually any map
you're going to see a similar pattern
and so what was the second part of your
question
New York City has a very outstanding
Bureau of TB control and I think they
clearly have learned from the example of
the early 1990s yeah I mean I think the
structures are in place the the improved
surveillance improved mechanisms for
ensuring treatment completion I do think
that the that the city would be prepared
to deal with in
the cases in New York I believe are
comparable to the cases the case rate in
the u.s. overall I am NOT very familiar
with the u.s. case rate but I believe
they're roughly on the same level
I mean TV is much much more a problem of
particularly Southeast Asia and
sub-saharan Africa so the highest case
rate is in Southeast Asia the highest
number of cases is in sub-saharan Africa
and the extent of the problem there
completely
dwarfs the problem in in New York City
or anywhere in the u.s. certainly the
care that patients receive is very good
quality care and they're also given a
variety of ancillary services so they
have access to substance use treatment
they have counseling etc there's a whole
array of social services that go along
with with the healthcare I mean really
it's the it's the consistent medication
that is critical but certainly in the
hospital they're being provided with a
lot of things that they wouldn't
possibly get if they were living in
their ordinary situation I mean this is
kind of an ironic feature of this is
that we give them these these this kind
of care and then they're cured and then
they go back to wherever they were
before they before they were diagnosed
with TB
would you mind I know it's a small room
but we're actually recording this so
people could see that's what kind of
gave some first thank you my question is
just immigrant contribute to the tepees
search and especially drug-resistant TB
and is that part possible to increase
the TB cases in New York what kind of
action on that yeah I mean in New York
City the case among immigrants were not
responsible for the majority of cases I
mean this was very much associated with
resident cases
indigenous cases to New York City I mean
there was concern about obviously in New
York City being a global hub and the
movement of the many immigrant
communities back and forth to their home
communities but I'd have to I want to
look back at the data again but overall
the that was not a responsible for a
major number of cases thank you based on
that the history that you described in
TV in New York City it seems that
legislation was an important tool of of
leverage as opposed to something that
was used very often and that's probably
the case for the history of many public
health programs but today some of those
legislative foundations are being taken
down by concerns of government intrusion
and and and privacy some of which are
very legitimate concerns what do you
think so can you give an example what do
you have in mind with that okay for
example there are there are some there's
some legislation in place in the in the
state of Oregon that puts and puts in
place some some of the automated
immunization systems that children's can
be put into a system automatically and
that the information cannot be used for
anything else right but but now the
government is saying well you know I
think we will want to use this
information for other things and they're
convincing the legislature that that is
in fact a good thing I'm not so sure
that but it is because it's just a
matter of trust that goes back to to how
the system was originally set up and
wondering if you have any thoughts or
advice about some of these systems that
are really dependent on legislature to
legislation to continue to operate
that's a fascinating question I mean I
know the the immunization registry story
very well I think it's interesting that
you are suspicious of Gov
organs efforts you know the immunization
registry so I'm not actually suspicious
that governor but you don't think that
it's a good idea that they want to
expand the uses of some of the data in
this
actually I don't in this case I think
it's a good idea but I don't think it's
a good idea to kind of do something
that's against the way a system was
originally set up and to use data for
other purposes for which it was not
designed I think it's a good idea but
not a good idea to do it by
administrative me yeah I mean I guess
there it would depend on the kind of
usage I mean there there's there's many
things in that question I'm trying to
think of which is the way to respond I
mean the immunization registry is an
interesting case because of the
resurgence of anti vaccination ISM and
the country and the why for the
suspicion that people have and I thought
you were going to bring up the example
in Texas where the Texas immunization
registry had to purge thousands and
thousand elements immunization records
because of the angry demands from
parents and you don't believe in the
safety of immunization so that's a whole
other issue I mean yeah that's an
example of what I'm talking about yeah I
mean one issue that you raised
specifically on this this issue of
legislation is whether it's better to
enact public health policies through
legislation or through administrative
regulations you know in in theory
legislation provides more transparency
and more democracy to the extent that
people can give their input into
legislation as opposed to administrative
lawmaking where public health officials
you know rewrite the health code you
know there are indirect mechanisms of
accountability for them through whoever
is the executive who appointed them so
I'm not sure which one is better I mean
through legislation enacting public
health policies through legislation may
open the process to a lot of people who
don't know very much about public health
and may have some very misguided ideas
about public health I mean a lot of the
wurst really pernicious aids-related
legislation in the 1980s came around
from legislators that was entirely
motivated by bigotry and hatred of
homosexuals and drug users so that's an
example of where legislation may not be
such a good thing even if it increases
public it's sort of democratic
participation I mean to gosh this is
such an interesting question I feel like
I've lost the thread of your progress
well I think I think you've answered the
question is that it it depends on the
situation and that appears that
sometimes legislation is a good tool and
other times administration's their
public health law as the field has
really boomed in the last decade or so
it's attracted a lot of interest and
there's increasing recognition I think
among many health authorities that
legislate law and legislation and
regulation is it was an extremely
powerful tool for advancing public
health and that that kind of flourishing
of public health law has has brought to
people's attention a lot of really
interesting issues around how do you
write your legislation so that it's not
over broad how do you make the
legislative intent clear etc etc thank
you thank you this was fascinating and I
have a couple questions that are no
doubt answered in your new book one's a
technical question about other things
such as negative pressure rooms which I
think were used first up here at st.
Luke's as I recall I know if it was
first but they were used yeah and then
also it seems to me I wrote something
about a new test that came out of the
American Society of microbiology first
and or maybe a CAC and then was used to
oh very early to test the those folks
who were being arraigned before they
went in the prison system so the first
question I have a third one oh and the
okay and that's something of my
ignorance what up until the time of
protease inhibitors let's say really
when they began to be used widely up say
96 or 97 how many of the HIV folks also
had TB here in New York City not in
Africa I don't know okay so so the first
question about negative pressure rooms
that actually I do have something on
that and in the book and it's a very
interesting story so one of the real
problems which I didn't talk so much
about was that hospitals were just doing
an abysmal job of managing their TB
cases they were the the doctors were not
treating it well and the the
administrative procedures were just
sloppy and so positive chest x-rays
would fail to be placed in patients
charts medication orders wouldn't get
transmitted properly and one of the
things that you that you have to do when
you isolate TB patients is ensure that
the room is at negative air pressure to
the out to the outside hallways so the
the the the disease doesn't spread and
so hospitals had an enormous kind of
hill to climb in bringing their care up
to standard and a lot of the hospitals
spent of would spend a fortune on these
negative air pressure rooms but then
would not put bathrooms in the room so
that patients with TB were in a negative
air pressure room and then they would go
walking down the hallway past how many
other rooms so they could use a shared
bathroom so the issue of getting
hospitals up to code that was one of the
one of the most time-consuming and
laborious things that Tom Frieden and
his team did because you know it could
be very difficult to exert leverage over
the staffs of all of them there were so
many hospitals in the city your second
question was Oh about the test I
actually I do not know about this test
so I will defer to maybe if we have a
physician in the audience Steve or
anyone who knows
the city actually apartment health has
some data which I think they're actually
process
now I thought something was given to
some test was given within arraignment
and maybe 92 93 91 something like that
uh okay well I can I can look back and
what I have I mean I have no idea how
sensitive and specific it was it is just
a kind of idea of doing a preliminary
isolation before they went into the
arraignment in Rikers or whatever mm-hmm
I don't know and then you're a third
question so the number of hiv-positive
people with TB HIV would not be known
because HIV wasn't reportable and so
nobody really knew how many people with
HIV were in the city in terms of well
they've diagnosed CDC estimates right
yeah I mean in terms of diagnosed cases
of AIDS I would actually have to go back
and look at my files I'm actually I
don't I don't have that number in my
head I mean it's a really interesting
question
which I don't I don't know the answer in
my head yeah first of all thank you
and I wanted to ask you talk you talked
a lot in our previous discussion and
then also in your lecture about the
differences of public health agencies
dealing with the social or environmental
factors of disease versus the more
medical technical or curative factors of
disease and obviously ideally there
would be a very good balance between the
two in terms of funding and resources
but public health agencies only have a
limited amount of funds so I was
wondering what your personal opinion was
in terms of you know what the percentage
of allocation should be not exactly but
you know generally towards preventative
and environmental measures as opposed to
curative measures well I mean I think
your question gets at an important point
underscore which is that public health
professionals politically are not
powerful actors at all compared to the
very
interest groups in society who are
fighting for a piece of the budget I
mean public health as a field is not at
all powerful and so you know the
question of their never mind their
mandate their ability to affect these
various societal conditions that they
might want to I think is is really in
question I mean it's the question of
allocation of health care dollars on
prevention versus cure is is a very
complicated one I'm not sure I'm not
sure ice and say again your question
well I was wondering what I mean
obviously there's a range of
possibilities but well your personal
opinion was on how much a public health
agency should embrace the attempt to
affect social and environmental
conditions as well as allocating for
treatment well there are there are a
wide range of things that might be done
to affect social conditions that are
have to do with basic features of a
capitalist society that I think are well
beyond the ability of public health
professionals I mean I'm in a School of
Public Health so my feeling is that
public health should always get more
money but of course that's that's
special pleading I mean if you look at
the overall health care budget a tiny
fraction of Health dollars in the u.s.
are spent on prevention I mean
regardless of how you define prevention
very little of the money goes towards
prevention and most of it goes towards
curative medicine so any kind of change
in that in that balance I think would be
a change in the right direction thank
you
so just building on my earlier question
about readiness so in this particular TB
outbreak or series of outbreaks d-o-t
worked as an effective measure for
countering the spread of the virus but
so we hear all the time about the spread
of these new novel legal pathogens like
ranging from ecole
one57 h72 the flu all of which make the
host body weaker and you did mention
that TB attacks when the host body or
the immune system is weakened so in the
case that there was a citywide
appearance of one of these pathogens
again it could be bacterial or viral and
origin would you say that that the
amount of TB first of all do you think
that an enormous amount of TB cases
would result and second of all do you
think that the city would be able to
deal with this massive info influx given
given the fact that do T does require I
guess a significant amount of personnel
and also resources to carry out
effectively so you're talking about the
appearance of a new microorganism that
increased incidence of TB or any or any
pathogen that would weaken the immune
system and allow dormant TB for example
to become symptomatic and then that
symptomatic TB would in turn result in
increased transmission to people who are
already already weakened by the initial
bacteria and you could just have this
enormous spread yeah I mean you can you
can always imagine sort of doomsday
scenarios I mean I think it would depend
on on the nature of what the pathogen
was on the extent of it on I mean again
I think the city has a very good TB
control infrastructure and the systems
around the city in terms of reporting is
much better than it used to be the
relationship between the Health
Department in terms of reporting of of
healthcare facilities of conditions is
much better than it used to be it could
be a lot better but it's much better
than it used to be so I think that the
city is would probably be
well-positioned but you know in in some
kind of dire science fiction scenario
who knows okay let me make these the two
last questions so yep just um they were
just back to the question of magic
bullets versus social and economic
change were there some other things
going on like finding houses for housing
for people with HIV and trying to
improve conditions in some
I don't know if there was in some of
those homeless shelters and so on that
might also have had some impact
perhaps not as much as co2 but yeah it's
a it's that's that's an important point
I'm glad you bring that up so one of the
things that the city tried to do was to
provide separate housing for homeless
hiv-positive people and homeless people
with AIDS because they were particularly
vulnerable to transmission in shelters
and there are actually many lawsuits
against the city by Housing Works in
other aids service organizations and and
so the city did do that and i and and
Frieden and his team when they talked
about the measures that had been
effective mentioned that is one of the
things that probably had an effect it's
you know when multiple things are
happening at the same time it's
sometimes difficult to tease out the
effects but given the significance of
transmission in shelters among
hiv-positive people it is almost
certainly the case that providing
separate segregated housing for
hiv-positive people and for people with
AIDS had an effect on it I mean it
really I I have to concede sort of the
limitations of the analytic categories
that I'm using because do you call that
a targeted intervention do you call that
or is does that rise to the level of
sort of a broad-based social reform the
fact that you're providing housing for
people with HIV I'm not sure shelters
that you showed the picture of where
they like now are they saying so yeah I
mean this is interesting the so the fort
armory shelter is now the Nike track and
field Hall of Fame and there are now
track meets where there used to be
thousands and thousands of cause there
is still a homeless shelter in that
facility but it's only a fraction of the
size a couple of months ago the
Coalition for the homeless which has
been very harshly critical of
Bloomberg's policies issued a press
release saying that the number of people
in the city's homeless shelters is at an
all-time high and I actually do not
follow that closely the have not
followed closely the recent the
Bloomberg policies on homeless
so the worst of the shelters were the
barracks style shelters were closed and
people were moved to different kinds of
housing so the picture that I showed
that is is not the standard anymore you
know by the way there were track meets
then too I used to run around that track
a lot of people did it was one of the
only places you could hold indoor track
needs for high schoolers and the the
mid-1980s and so you know you were
running around those beds so yeah I
think that may be one reason
you know why well anyway we could talk
about this but but it was one of those
rare instances where like kind of middle
class kids you know would have
encountered kind of homelessness and the
public health problems associated with
that and in a way that you know kind of
made it visible but yeah I mean the
other thing is that at this time in the
in the 98 like late 80s and 90s homeless
was much much more visible than it is
now I mean it was really just I mean
were people living in New York City at
that time I mean it was just it was
extremely in your face all over and I
think it is is less so whether that
means that the homeless policies are
better or not I'm I don't know thank you
for your talk you have mentioned before
that the urban nature you know New York
City compounded the problems that you
know the decline the so-called decline
of TV caused and how eventually TV came
to have a resurgence in New York City
what do you think what is your opinion
on the FSK advocacy of d-o-t and more
rural settings mm-hmm well DDOT has been
used in all kinds of settings all over
the world and the data are pretty
consistent I mean when when Tom Frieden
went to India everybody said you can
never do this in India it's just like it
would be completely ridiculous with such
a different kind of social geography and
landscape and it he you know he has the
data to prove it so it's been used I
mean it doesn't really
it's it's it is adaptable to different
kinds of social landscapes I mean it's a
model I think that's one of the reasons
it's successful is that it's a model
that can be made to work provided that
you have the adequately trained outreach
worker and the pills I mean one of the
big problems is just that the many of
these areas just don't have access to
the drugs but if you have the outreach
worker and you have the pill that's kind
of all you need I mean and and you know
a car to get there or to get to where
you have to be able to get to where the
patients are well I want to thank James
Colegrove he's just completed the
marathon four and a half hour session of
seminar discussions with two different
classes and now a public lecture and a
Q&A session and so I think he's gone
above and